we're on problem 60 given the equation y
is equal to X to the N y is equal to X
to the N where x is greater than 0 and n
is less than zero which statement is
valid so let's see x is greater than 0
and n is less than zero so the exponent
is negative but the base is positive so
I'll just tell you right now your gut
reaction might be say oh if I have a
negative exponent maybe I somehow end up
with a negative number somehow you have
to remember a negative exponent it just
tells you that it's really just the
inverse of the positive exponent so this
is equal to 1 over X to the minus n
right and if n is less than zero then
minus n is greater than 0 right so you
could say this is the same thing as 1
over X to some other letter M where m is
minus n but then M will be greater than
0 right so no matter how negative this
exponent is especially if this base is
positive you're going to end up with a
positive number your end up with very
small fractions if this gets large
enough right it could be 1 over X to the
hundredth power so I'm think so it could
be a very small number it can approach
zero but it'll always be a positive
number so why is always going to be
greater than zero it's Joyce a problem
61 if X is a real number which best
describes the value of x for which the
inequality the square root of x greater
than 0 is true so I'm assuming we're
dealing with with the real numbers and
well yeah I guess because you know if I
get an imaginary number here it's
actually just even hard to compare it in
terms of magnitude 20 so they're
actually just asking us what the domain
is right what X is can we put in here
and get a get an answer that where we
can make some type of sense out of this
statement so obviously I could put a
positive x here right X could be greater
than 0 NE x greater than 0 will have a
square root and all of their square
roots will be greater than 0 I mean you
could square both sides of that equation
and you get x is greater than 0 can you
you could put X equal to 0 there but
then the inequality wouldn't be true
right because the square root
0 square root of 0 is equal to 0 so if
you put X is equal to 0 there that would
work it could you can take the square
root of 0 but it just won't make the
inequality true so X can't be equal to 0
so X could be 0 greater than 0 it can't
be greater than or equal to 0 not all
values of x work I can't put a negative
number in there and I mean you know they
say no values of x now sure we can put
any positive number there that works so
the answer is a next problem turn the
page all right okay let me copy and
paste it
which of the following conclusions is
true about the statement below x squared
is equal to the square root of x alright
so once again let's think about it a
little bit let's think about it a little
bit x squared is equal to square root of
x I mean it works it definitely works
for the number one and it works for the
number zero right I mean if you square
both sides of that equation you get X to
the fourth is equal to X and then if you
a suit you know X could be equal zero
but if you assume that X does not equal
zero you can divide both sides of this
equation by X and you get x to the third
is equal to one and the only number that
I know works for that is the number one
but anyway the statement is always true
no it's not always true I put a 2 there
is two squared equal to the square root
of two no four does not equal the square
root of two so the statement is not
always true the statement is true when X
is negative no X can't even be negative
you can't take the square root of the
negative number you'd end up with
imaginary numbers and just gets very
strange the statement is true when x is
equal to zero shore it could be 0 the
statement is never true no it's clearly
it's true when x is equal to 0 or x is
equal to 1 so the answer is C I didn't
even have to do this stuff on the side
right here but hopefully it was
instructive next problem I've copied it
now I have pasted it all right we try
with the larger pen abelardo wants to
create several different seven character
screen names he wants to use
arrangements of the first three letters
of his first name Abe that's why it's
neatly made his name abelardo followed
by arrangements of the four digits in
1984 the year of his birth how many
different screen names can he create in
this way all right so he's got seven so
think about it let's just think about
each slot right so slot number one that
that pens too fat slot number one slot
number two slot number three four five
67 so slot number one how many different
choices can he put in there right he can
put an a a B or an e there right so he
has three different choices for slot
number one under that in a different
color he has three different choices for
slot number one once he picks slot
number one how many choices does he have
left first slot number two well he has
two letters left of out of the a B and E
right so he has only two options left
and once he gets a slot number three he
kind of has to just pick whatever left
over letter is there an a B and E so he
only has one option but then when he
gets to the fourth digit now he's
starting to pick from 1984 for the
fourth digit once he has four options he
could pick the one the nine the eighth
or the four he has four options then on
the fifth digit he would have picked one
of the four so he has three of them left
by the six digital he has two of them
left by the seventh digit he's forced to
pick whatever is left over what he
hasn't picked yet he has one digit left
so the combinations you just multiply
all of them I see three times two is six
times 1 is 6 6 times 4 is 24 24 times
three is 72 72 times two is 144 times
one is 144 so there's a hundred forty
four different screen names he can
create in this way next problem 64 64
copied it and now I'm pasting it a train
is made up of a locomotive seven
different cars and a caboose if the
locomotive must be first and the caboose
must be last how many different ways can
the train view ordered so we don't even
have to worry about the the locomotive
in the caboose right they're always
going to be in the same position the
locomotives first caboose is last so we
just have to worry about the seven
different cars the order that they're in
right so let's talk about it's really
the same problem as the last one it's in
some in some ways it's a little bit
easier so let's just say that's the
position position 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 and
let's say we just have to decide which
car we put in each position or how many
different options do we have so say we
filling the slot starting with position
1 well we have seven cars to choose from
seven cars right the seven is different
from the best design including the
locomotive in the caboose right so we
have seven cars to pick from we've
picked one of them then in slot two we
have six cars to pick from slot 3 we
have five cars to pick from right
because we've already picked two and
then slot for four cars to pick from
three cars two cars and then slot seven
we've already picked six of the car so
whatever is left over we have to pick so
let's see what this number is 1 times 2
is to 2 times 3 is 6 6 times 4 is 24 24
times 5 is what 120 120 times 6 10 tries
720 720 x 7 i'm just gonna have to do a
little bit of multiplication here on the
side 720 x 77 times 0 is 0 7 times 2 is
14 7 times 7 is 49 plus 1 is 50 50 40 so
there's 5040 different ways that the
train can be ordered C next problem
okay maybe I'll just clear all of this
all right let me copy the
all right Theresa and Julia are among 10
students who have applied for trip to
Washington DC to students from the group
will be selected at random from for the
trip what is the probability that
Theresa and Julia will be the two
students selected so let's think about
this there are 10 students have applied
for the trip to students from the group
will be selected at random for the trip
what is the probability that Theresa and
Julia will be the two students selected
alright so let's think about student one
selected and student to selected right
what's the probability that Teresa is
the first student so what's the
probability that we get Teresa and then
we get Julia the Teresa is the first
student selected and then Julia is the
second student selected well the
probability that Teresa is the first
well let me take a step back there's two
ways that what they want to happen could
happen right that Teresa and Julia will
be the two students selected either
Teresa is the first student selected and
then Julia is the second or julia is the
first student selected and Teresa is the
second so if we figure out the
probability of this happening and the
probability of this happening then we
could just add those probabilities
together and then we have the
probability of either of those happening
all right so let's see the probability
of Teresa happening so let's see
probability of Teresa is let me do this
in a different color there's 10 students
so there's probably picked Teresa first
and then once we put Teresa first the
probability that we pick Julia next well
now there's nine students left right
because you've already picked Teresa so
there's a one and nine chance you pick
Julia alright so that is equal to one
and 90 so there's a one a ninety chance
of this happening there's a 1 290 chance
of that happening and then what's the
chance of this happening what's the
chance of that happening what's the same
thing this is 1 and 10 and this is one
in one and 90 right and so you have a 1
in 90 chance of it happening and so what
is the probability of either of these
things happening of this combination or
this combination well you just add them
together and you get to
out of 90 which is equal to one out of
45 which is choice a and I'm out of time
see you in the next video